vamos a las noticias de la salud con más
Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela un día importante hoy
conmemoramos el día de la intolerancia
cero contra la mutilación genital
femenina hablemos de esta práctica que
increíblemente todavía muchas personas
no conocen no muchas personas no la
conocen y además no conocen tampoco lo
extendida que llega a estar después
revisaremos las cifras empezamos con la
definición de la Organización Mundial de
la Salud para hablar de esta práctica
básicamente se trata de cualquier tipo
de lesión a los genitales femeninos sin
ningún motivo médico implica cortes
implica extracciones parciales de estos
órganos que no tienen ningún tipo de
beneficios para la salud al contrario no
que pueden tener riesgos tanto
inmediatos como a largo plazo para la
salud de las niñas y de las mujeres hay
varios tipos de hablación una palabra
que también se usa para describir esta
práctica algunos solo implican el corto
Bueno solo entre comillas no el corte
del clítoris otros implican también la
extracción de los labios de la vulva
llega a implicar a veces algo que se
llama infibulación que es estrechar la
apertura vaginal por ejemplo pues
cosiendo los labios por encima esto pues
como decíamos existen muchos tipos pero
básicamente se entiende cualquier tipo
de lesión a los genitales que no tengan
ningún tipo de motivo médico que
dejemoslo muy claro es una violación de
derechos humanos y que daña
completamente la vida de las mujeres
ahora hablemos precisamente de eso
Cuántas personas son Víctimas de estas
prácticas pues como decíamos Ángeles una
práctica relativamente extendida todavía
hoy en día según cifras de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud también
se calcula que son 200 millones las
niñas y mujeres que en todo el mundo
viven pues habiendo sido víctimas
habiendo sido afectadas por esta
práctica además cada año son tres
millones las que están en riesgo de
sufrir una ablación y se practica en 30
países sobre todo de África de medio
oriente también algunos países asiáticos
Aunque está extendido también algunas
otras partes del mundo no podemos dejar
de decir
Europa por ejemplo siguen habiendo miles
de casos también anuales para entender
un poco más de qué estamos hablando
recuperamos el testimonio de una
entrevista de agosto pasado a una autora
francesa que precisamente hablaba de
esto
yo hablo de violación porque es la
invasión del cuerpo de una mujer sin
consentimiento en lo más íntimo por eso
lo llamó violación hay una amputación
cuando hablamos de la mutilación por
supuesto se siente ira pero intentamos
entender que a través del acto de la
mutilación genital femenina es algo que
se transmite de generación en generación
que nuestras madres lo han sufrido
nuestras abuelas lo han sufrido
pensando siempre que era lo correcto y
que era lo que estaba bien pero no se
imaginan la cantidad de daños que hacen
a la fisiología y a las emociones de las
personas precisamente hablemos de las
consecuencias sobre la salud de esta
práctica como decías son a muchos rangos
muchas aristas de la salud que se ven
afectadas a raíz de la mutilación a
general femenina lo más inmediato
hablamos por supuesto de la posibilidad
de una hemorragia también de infecciones
aparte pues de un dolor muy intenso pero
es que a largo plazo son muchos más los
que se van acumulando por ejemplo
problemas urinarios también de
infecciones pues por ejemplo en la
vejiga en la vagina también son muchas
cosas que se van acumulando con el paso
del tiempo problemas menstruales hay
mujeres que incluso tienen problemas
para que les baje adecuadamente la
menstruación Y eso implica también pues
problemas a largo plazo los riesgos por
supuesto en las complicaciones a la hora
del parto en mujeres también que a raíz
de haber tenido una ablación tienen que
tener un parto por cesárea
obligatoriamente digamos sin la
posibilidad de intentar un parto vaginal
Y eso sin hablar de los problemas a
salud de Pues en el respecto de la Salud
Mental hay mujeres que tienen estrés
postraumático después de sufrir esta
experiencia las dificultades que se
acumulan sobre la percepción del propio
cuerpo y también hablemos de la salud
sexual una parte básica de la salud de
las mujeres y de todo el mundo que en
general además ahí radica la base de
esta práctica no poder controlar la
sexualidad de la mujer quitarle agencia
poder de decisión y de la posibilidad de
tener el placer y no Simplemente tener
sexo a raíz de la reproducción no tener
digamos saca esta libertad de tener
decisión sobre las propias decisiones
alrededor de la vida sexual y estamos
claras en que cuando hay control de la
vida sexual hay un machismo de por medio
que no se ha podido erradicar
estructural y bueno Esto sucede
principalmente en las Naciones africanas
es una cultura muy extendida que no se
ha podido erradicar pero también sucede
en algunas comunidades latinoamericanas
Colombia por ejemplo es uno de esos
lugares donde ocurre Así es hay casos
Aunque eso es una práctica que la OMS
teatra de residual en el Continente por
suerte en Estados Unidos por ejemplo hay
algunos casos de pues casos y de
migración de comunidades migrantes que
lo siguen practicando en el país y luego
también en cambio en América Latina como
bien decías está el caso de Colombia y
algunas comunidades indígenas por
ejemplo en la comunidad en Vera donde se
practica sobre todo el corte del
clítoris y como decías es difícil
erradicar esta práctica porque llega a
formar parte de la cosmovisión de muchas
comunidades que luego se resisten no
como una especie de imposición desde
fuera que no se practique esto cuando lo
que se tiene es que trabajar en conjunto
con estas comunidades para demostrar las
malas consecuencias sobre la salud de
las niñas y de las mujeres que tiene
esto y a mí me gustaría también cerrar
con una reflexión no y es que a pesar de
que hay muchos lugares en el mundo donde
por suerte no se practica la ablación y
la mutilación genital femenina si hay un
desconocimiento general sobre los
órganos sobre los genitales femeninos en
todo el mundo también muy enraizado al
final el patriarcado y en estas
desigualdades de género que existen en
la medicina que hace que muchas veces
estemos muy desconectadas también de
nuestros propios cuerpos y esto supone
no otros tipos Pues de control también o
de mutilaciones distintas por suerte no
físicas de nuestros propios cuerpos y ni
siquiera a veces es la mayoría de los
casos gracias a usted Gracias